listening to music while you train is
cheating so what you're telling me is
that the Silence of your own dark
thoughts isn't enough of a soundtrack
and you've had to crowdsource insults
from the internet self-narrate it and
then play it to yourself while you train
that's it I do that sometimes yes
yes have you got your phone on you right
now I want to hear it I don't travel my
phone yeah my phone does not go with me
anywhere why is that like right now I'm
with you a lot of times people are in
conversations or they're elsewhere you
may think they're with you but they're
not that phone is the biggest
distraction in the world so when it
comes time for the phone I'm on the
phone we're not I don't use it I'm all
about being present where I'm at